رسالتنا
للمراه السعوديه انه نبغى نسمعك وينك
نبغى نسمع موسيقتك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بدينا نعزف سوا ب 2022
الفرقه مكونه من ثينك عازفه الايقاعات
ومش عازفه ديسك ونورا المغنيه وعازفات
الكيبورد وانا هيا اعزف الجيتار الكهربائي
هو اصعب شيء احس كان انا شخصيا كان صعب
بالنسبه لي اروح اعزف معه شباب انا ما
اعرفهم وبدا اصلا الشباب ياسسوا مع بعض
جروباتهم وطريقتهم فصعب يكون في نوع من
الانسيابيه في التناغم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ممنوع موسيقى سيره يرتكز على موسيقى ذلك
اراك المشهوره او الممزوجه
بموسيقى سواء كانت اجنبيه او عربيه
[تصفيق]
احنا نكتب اوريجينال ميوزك وطبعا اكثر شيء
اثر فينا هو موسيقى بشكل كبير تاثير
الموسيقى السعوديه على موسيقتنا تجي من
المقامات العربيه واحنا حابين نتمسك
بتراثنا وبحضارتنا وثقافتنا
وهذا ليش نستعمل المقامات العربيه في
موسيقتنا
[موسيقى]
بموضوع احنا مره مهتمين فيه وينعكس
بالموسيقتنا وهو موضوع الصحه النفسيه او
[موسيقى]
وحسينا بطاقه يعني ما نقدر ما نقدر نشرحها
بالكلام
[موسيقى]
الخطط المستقبليه حقتنا انه نكون البوم
عندنا احنا مكونات الالبوم بس التسجيل هو
شويه صعب والشيء اللي احنا مره حبينا
نسويه بالمستقبل القريب انه نعزف بمدن في
السعوديه زي جده مدن في الشرقيه العلا في
الجنوب نبغى نتوسع ونعزف بمدن عربيه جمهور
عربي وغير عربي في بلاد اجنبيه كمان
[موسيقى]